what's going on guys this is rob and it
recently occurred to me as i was going
through and trying to figure out what
story i was gonna do in celebration of
the newest trailer for doctor strange we
never did damn nation and we kind of
have to right i mean we've done a lot of
the other stuff right we did the initial
run by jason aaron and then i don't
remember if we did dennis hopeless's run
um and then we did the donnie kate's run
and then uh damnation really comes
directly after that and then we can go
into like the death of doctor strange
which is all just this great big huge
cohesive story so here's the thing this
takes place immediately after the events
of secret empire so explanation for
people who don't know anything about
secret empire if you do bear with me if
you don't listen up so the idea behind
secret empire is that basically the red
skull got his hands on a cosmic cube and
used it to change the history of steve
rogers so instead of him growing up to
be a patriot and becoming captain
america instead he ended up becoming an
agent of hydra and then eventually
seized control of hydra and then
successfully conquered north america and
then set his sights unlike the rest of
the world ultimately he was defeated but
during his time as stevel as we love to
call him here in the comic book
community evil steve rogers um he had
actually basically destroyed las vegas
literally torched the whole city and
killed everybody in i mean i don't know
why the destruction of a city and just
millions of deaths are funny to me but
but you guys get what i'm saying right
he literally just torched the whole town
uh and so following that
las vegas was kind of like this
testament to the fact that like stephen
was beyond saving right there was no way
to basically get him back and bring back
steve rogers and so in order to fix that
marvel basically used some wizardry and
then just kind of imagined him out of
thin air and then brought turned like
imaginary steve rogers into real steve
rogers and then steven was killed during
todd haasey codes captain america run
it's weird check out the secret the
secret empire story itself was amazing
evil captain america was the coolest
captain america had been in like 50
years but make sure you guys go check
that out it'll be down in the
description it's a really really cool
story having said that the way this
picks up is basically with doctor
strange essentially coming along and
then basically fixing new york and
resurrecting it now for stephen strange
himself right his powers have
experienced a huge increase and the
reason why is because for a time during
donnie kate's uh doctor strange run loki
had actually stolen the mantle or taken
the mantle from steven strange and so
loki basically became the new sorcerer
supreme now eventually loki got his ass
absolutely handed to him by the century
which was amazing really was the void
more than the century but eventually the
century the void whatever working
alongside doctor strange essentially
ousted loki and then doctor strange went
back to being the sorcerer supreme and
got a boost in his powers along the way
and so during this time you know this is
this kind of magical boost this is the
way he's able to basically restore las
vegas to the way that it looked before
it was destroyed and then in turn
resurrect everybody who died here's the
problem with this right las vegas is not
called the devil's playground for no
reason when las vegas is resurrected and
everything returns to normal suddenly
like the ground starts shaking and this
just enormous tower just erupts from
like underground right just explodes
outward in the middle of las vegas and
that's when you get like this grand
opening right the hotel inferno as it's
kind of given to us by like this guy
right this guy who just looks kind of
crazy but the thing about this is that
as soon as this happens and like doctor
strange is given like a vip card he
immediately knows what's going on right
he's like okay so like obviously this is
a whole thing with like mephisto right
like hotel inferno the devil's hotel all
that kind of stuff so he picks up on
what's happening pretty fast the funny
thing is that as he gets in there you
have a combination of things happening
you have like regular people who were in
there and then you have like a bunch of
demons and stuff running around but the
people who were there don't really seem
to know exactly what's going on right i
mean they almost seem to be just sort of
ignoring it to a degree and so in the
middle of all this stephen strange is
met by the arrival of mephisto now the
funny thing about this is that of course
as soon as mephisto appears anywhere
right you immediately know that like
something nefarious is going on the
other funny thing here is that mephisto
doesn't look like his normal self he
looks like a like a rich hotel owner
so it's kind of funny seeing him taking
an undertaking this role but then
ultimately he sits steven strange down
and just kind of explains to him exactly
what had been going on now here's one
thing to grasp about mephisto as we go
through this right that mephisto is one
of many iterations of what you would
call satan in marvel comics technically
speaking the idea of like satan right so
like the the fallen angel from the you
know abrahamic religions right so you
know the god of abraham all that kind of
stuff that guy doesn't really exist in
marvel comics we thought he did in terms
of like it being the one below all
during uh al ewing's incredible hulk run
that's actually not the case really
immortal hook run but that's really not
the case instead like basically the one
below all was just what happens when the
one above all essentially hulks out
right it's his version of the hulk right
it's just crazy evil version but the
idea is you have all kinds of what are
called hell lords here right you've got
damon hellstrom you've got all kinds of
people here mephisto is simply one of
them now the reality is that among the
hell lords they're all basically vying
for like the most number of human souls
they can possibly get and the reason why
is because marvel has long since and
this is really back during the days of
roy thomas marvel has long since put
forward this idea that like the hell
lords will all go to war against one
another officially and whoever has the
most number of human souls will
basically win uh but that's how all
these guys essentially work the way
mephisto works is that if you make a
deal with him you'll get what you want
but it'll be in like a twisted and in
really a useless capacity and then
ultimately you'll end up finding
yourself being taken to health so a
really good example of this is during
the story thanos wins when uh when
basically thanos showed up on earth and
started killing all the superheroes that
punisher made a deal with mephisto to
gain the power necessary to kill thanos
and in doing so mephisto made punisher
the ghost rider the funny thing is that
punisher couldn't leave the earth so
thanos was already gone so he had the
power to kill thanos but he couldn't use
it and then when the time came when he
would ultimately be destroyed uh his
soul would be taken by mephisto that's
kind of how those deals work right it's
not really a fair deal because he is
kind of a god of tricks and lies right
as a god of deceit but in the middle of
all this because of what had happened
specifically with the destruction of las
vegas that seemingly in the aftermath of
that when it was destroyed by hydra
basically everybody who was there at the
time including the city were just
whisked away to the realm of mephisto
right because las vegas is a city of sin
and so during that time they would
literally just torment people's souls
they would torture them all kinds of
stuff it was it was a field day for
mephisto but when doctor strange came
along and then basically resurrected uh
the entirety of las vegas and all the
people in it he essentially took all
those people away from mephisto and so
that's why mephisto has erected a hotel
here in las vegas to basically get those
people back but the other part of this
and this is what's kind of interesting
here is that as he's in this place he's
like i mean you know i guess i could
kind of get used to it right he's like i
mean the people here in this city they
are all really centers right like you
got prostitutes you got you got john
doe's you've got mobsters you got people
who owe money to the mob you got people
who are breaking and entering you've got
people who are just doing all kinds of
stuff and so what mephisto realizes is
that instead of simply just striking
deals with people intermittently across
the earth while operating in his realm
or at least his section of hell that
instead he could operate in the city of
las vegas and because people go to las
vegas to do things engage in you know
debauchery and things like that that
they simply just can't necessarily do in
their normal lives las vegas is
basically the best place to find
terrible people in order to steal their
souls
that's literally the goal of mephisto
and so that's why you start seeing these
things happening that he actually
invites doctor strange into like this
vault that he has and then you kind of
switch over to a moment where you have a
john doe with a prostitute and then
literally he's just like is it just me
or is it getting ridiculously hot in
here and the guy starts melting right at
the same time those people who were
committing like breaking and entering uh
they're basically torched right the
mobsters are basically torched and then
when steven strange starts to look at
the actual money uh that's being
presented to him by mephisto instead of
it having the face of like dead
presidents it's got the face of people's
souls in there that what mephisto's
doing is that as these people are
basically destroyed as he takes their
souls he puts their souls into money and
then puts the money into a vault it's
pretty crazy but kind of cool and the
funny thing is like with mephisto being
what he has i mean this is one thing to
understand it's a field day for this guy
and the funny thing is that it really is
all just subjective based on essentially
how mephisto feels so for example like
people like john does like this guy
who's cheating on his wife things like
that you know basically sleeping with a
prostitute that's uh that's kind of an
unforgivable thing right that's
something you can't necessarily let go
there's a guy who refuses to pay a
parking meter and mephisto is like done
right like that guy's soul belongs to me
because technically he's a liar right i
mean it's one of those funny things
about society right like on a societal
level we've all just kind of silently
agreed there are some lies that it's
okay to tell right like it's okay to lie
sometimes as long as your lies don't go
above like a certain threshold right you
know at that point then it's considered
to be an unforgivable thing with
mephisto it's not that way right a lie
is a lie is a lie right so if you're a
liar your soul belongs to him and that's
just it right that's all there is to it
it's pretty interesting right absolute
evil versus absolute good and he's just
kind of like i mean like like look at
this stephen strange like look at this
this this field day that i'm having here
right these people who are engaging in
like fixed boxing fights right all kinds
of stuff all these people who are all
sinners out here i'm surprised i never
came here before right this place is
just the the it's just the nature of
things right you as a human race you
guys are just bad people and it's been
that way since basically like the apple
in the garden of eden right it's just
always been that way it is in the nature
of you as human beings to just be
terrible things right to do terrible
things so like you know i want to expand
out we'll start in vegas right we'll
start out in las vegas you know we'll
build a little bit of a thing here and
then as time progresses right we're
going to be worldwide baby hotel inferno
mephisto we going worldwide son
it's one of those funny things and so
ultimately a deal is struck right now as
you guys know anybody who knows anything
about mephisto knows this guy's all
about deals he's all about bargains
right you never get a fair bargain when
you make a bargain with mephisto so
that's why if you go into it you have to
be able to have some way to get the
upper hand you basically have to
outsmart it right that's really what you
have to do so so doctor strange one of
the things to know is him making this
deal with mephisto he's got some kind of
an ace up his sleeve but what he says
here is that the people in this world
are not as bad as you make them out to
be and and ultimately like mephisto's
like are you serious like you really
think you really think that's the case
right you know and indoctrination is
like they may have made mistakes but
they always come through in the end and
so mephisto is like okay well if you're
so confident about that perhaps you'd
like to make a friendly wager and dr
strange is kinda like dude really this
is what you really want to do and
mephisto's like i know i know i know i
know man i'm predictable if not nothing
else but if you really believe in these
people if you really believe that
humanity is not as terrible as as i see
them as being then let's make a deal
right let's make a bargain so if you win
then it's back to my realm right i go
back to the realm of hell and and that
vault gets emptied all those people get
their souls back all that kind of stuff
now here's an important thing to
understand right the statement that
vault gets emptied that's where mephisto
trips you up because in the end this
whole thing could could easily end in
such a way where mephisto's kind of like
i said i would empty the vault i didn't
say i would give them their souls back
so it's like their souls go with me
right that kind of that's the kind of
thing mephisto would do right but it's
kind of like you know like like i'll go
back to my realm the vault will be
emptied everything will be cool but if i
win if i win i get your soul stephen
strange and let's be honest me in
possession of the soul of a sorcerer
supreme would give me all kinds of
bragging rights among the hell lords
right and so ultimately stephen strange
is like okay then we'll strike a deal
and that's when the fist so is like okay
then let's test these people let's test
the superhero friends that you know jane
foster who because jane foster was thor
at this point in time by sam wilson
falcon carol danvers black panther let's
test these guys let's see if they're
really as good as you make them out to
be or are they really as violent as i
think they are if i'm if i present them
with some kind of opportunity where they
can give themselves to me will they do
it or will they fight against me and so
ultimately he ends up using his power
and effectively turns the avengers into
ghost riders right turns into like these
ghost rider type beings and then
following that because steven strange
basically has to find some method of
performing or creating an army on his
own he can't readily do it because at
this point now they've got to be hands
off to a degree right they can't
necessarily intervene they can but they
can't you guys will see what i'm talking
about as a story goes on but ultimately
you end up having basically wong right
you kind of switch back to wong who of
course gets a knock at the door and it
turned out to be bats that is cool all
right here's the thing about bats right
quick little explanation about bats bats
was a basset hound that was adopted by
steven strange and then when loki was
sorcerer supreme he basically killed him
by accident and so doctor strange was
just like get out of here right when he
got his powers back he's never wanted to
see him again loki tried to find a way
to like fix it but i mean literally like
loki killed dr strange's dog right it
was just it was a dick thing to do and
so bats ended up coming back as like a
ghost basset hound there was also a time
a point where doctor strange cast a
spell so that instead of hearing barks
you could actually hear what he was
saying which is cool bats is awesome i
absolutely love bats and in fact i
remember getting on twitter when bats
died and i yelled at donnie capes i was
like really man you killed bats what's
your problem
i was so pissed but then bats came back
as a ghost so it makes everything okay
but the thing about this is that that
basically bats tells wong like hey man
there's something going on in vegas like
you need to fight you need to go look
and see what's going on there of course
wong peers under their cauldron you know
the whole thing where it gives them
visions all that kind of stuff and
realizes what's going on between dr
strange and and mephisto and so because
of this he realizes doctor strange
cannot win this on his own and if wong
were to go running off to las vegas to
fight mephisto he would be crushed like
that right i mean it would just it would
happen with a quickness wang does not
have the power to face off against a
demonic entity on the level of mephisto
very few people do right mephisto is
just that powerful and so in light of
that in light of that rob core wong does
the only thing he can do he says we will
call together a group of people who have
faced the the force of mephisto before
we will call these people together they
will be the hunter blade the knight moon
knight
the slayer elsa bloodstone who no one
cares about the order right brother
voodoo the man thing right the fist and
to lead the way to lead this group the
ghost rider in effect wong calls
together the midnight suns and man
man do the midnight suns let me tell you
something about the midnight sun
yeah i love the midnight suns man the
midnight suns are like just one of the
coolest groups ever right but literally
let me tell you something man like it's
meh what do when the midnight sun show
up on the scene all hell starts breaking
loose especially blade man let's say
some blade takes no prisoners but this
guy does not give damn he just shows up
and he's like everybody's gonna die
right it's just it's crazy when blade
chills anyway with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end
we will do part two next week thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace